where do you put magnus carlsen the
current world champion in the list of
all-time greats in terms of style
moments of brilliance consistency it's a
tricky question you know the moment you
start ranking yeah well do something
it's the I think it's it's it's not fair
because it's any new generation knows
much more about the game than their
previous one so when people say oh Gary
was the greatest Fisher was the greatest
Magnus was the greatest it disregard the
fact that the great players of the past
whether last year come a plank looking I
mean they knew so little about chess why
do they standards today just any kid you
know that spent a few years you know and
uh with his or her chess computer when
knows much more about the game simply
just because you actually have access to
this information and it has been
discovered generation after generation
we added more and more knowledge to the
game of chess it's about the gap between
the world champion and the rest of the
field so it's the now if you look at the
gap then proud of Fisher you know could
be on top but very short period of time
then you should also add a time factor
yeah I was on top not as big as but but
much longer so that's so and also unlike
Fisher I was succeeding next generation
yeah here's the question yeah let's see
if you still got the fire speaking of
the next generation because you did
succeed beating the next generation it's
close
okay well Anand short Anand the shear of
chromic is already 12 years younger so
that's a nice that's but still yet I I
competed with them and I just had beat
most of them and and I was still
dominant when I left at age of the 41 so
back to Magnus Magnus right consistency
is phenomenal the reason Magnus is on
top and it seems unbeatable today Magnus
is is a lethal combination of Fisher on
corpus which is very it's very unusual
because Fisher style was very dynamic
just fighting to the last point just
using every resource available Karpov
was very different
just yet an unparallel ability to use
the every piece with a maximum effect
just it's minimal resources always
produce maximum effect just so now
imagine that you merge these two styles
say oh it is it's it's like you know
it's a squeezing every stone for drop of
water but but doing it you know just you
know for 50 60 70 80 moves
I mean mangos could go on as long as
Fisher who is always passion and energy
and at the same time being as meticulous
and and and and and deadly as corporal
by just you know using every little
advantage so and yes good you know very
good else it's important I mean physical
conditions are by the way very important
so a lot of people don't recognize it
their latest study shows that chess
players burn thousands of calories
during the game so that puts him on the
top of this field of of the world campus
but again it's it's the discussion that
is I so recently an internet whether
garry kasparov always peek let's say
late eighties could beat Magnus Carlsen
today I mean it's totally irrelevant
because garriga's probably 1999 okay
it's played great chess but so I give
her a little about chess compared to
macros crossing 2019 who by the way
learn from me as well so that's why yeah
I'm extremely cautious in making any
judgment that involves you know time
gaps you ask you know soccer fans so
who's your favorite tell em Maradona or
Messi yeah yeah who's your favorite
Messi miss because maybe because younger
but that's simple your instinct answers
correct because you saw you didn't say
Maradona in action I saw all of them in
action so that's why but it's since you
know when I was you know just following
it in there just its pillion and
Maradona they were just you know there
were big stars and it's nice he's
already just get I I was gradually
losing interest
I'm just other things so I remember Pele
1970 the final match Brazil Italy so
there's a first world war World Cup
software I watched so that's the and and
actually my answer when it just where
they're just you know I because I I was
asked this question as well so I say
that is just while it's impossible to
choice I would sue probably go with
Maradona for simple reason the Brazilian
team in 1970 could have won without
Colette
it was absolutely great still could have
won maybe but it is the Argentinian team
in 1986 without Maradona would not be in
the 5s so this is and Messi he could
argue for that for an hour but yes you
could say if you ask Maradona if you
look in his eyes especially let's say
Garry Kasparov 99 he would have said I
was sure as hell would be Magnus Carlsen
just simply the confidence fire simply
because simply because again is just a
so mean action so this again it's it's
the age factor is important therefore
with a passion and energy and and being
equipped with all modern ideas but again
then you make in a very just important
assumption that you could empower Garry
Kasparov 89 with all ideas that have
been accumulated over 30 years that
would not be Gary the sport that would
be someone else because again I belong
to 1989 I was way ahead of the field and
I you know a bit Karpov several times in
a World Championship matches and I
crossed 2800 which by the way if you
look at the just in rating which is this
it's even today so this is this is the
rating that I retire so that says it's
still you know it's just it's a it's a
top two to three so that says this is
kerwin and eagle is about the same
rating now and I crossed 2,100 in 1990
we just look at the inflation when I
cross 2800 in in 1990 there was only one
player in 2700 category and I told the
carpet now he had more than 50 such as
you see this so if you add inflation so
I think my 28:51 it could probably could
be more valuable as Magnus 2882 which
was haha highest rating but anyway yeah
in our very hypotheticals
you